hey there folks so this is going to be a
really quick video just letting you know
what's going to be going on this week
because it's going to be a little bit
different than normal
long story made short i have the
upcoming launch of my novel dreams of
fire
there's a pre-order link if you want to
get the kindle edition but that is
launching uh at the start of june and
frankly i have a number of things that i
need to do to get on my tucks in a row
to be sure that that launch goes as well
as it possibly can
and i don't have the time to do that and
do my normal
video output so here's what we're doing
this week i'm kind of pushing everything
back originally there was going to be no
new video of my normal type on wednesday
or saturday
there will be a video on wednesday now
because something has come up that i
want to deal with while it's still
topical
there won't be a new video on saturday
that does not mean there will be no
content on this
channel what i've done instead is if you
go to the community tab
a little while ago i solicited questions
that i could answer in the form of
shorts
and that's what will be going on this
week short videos
answering your questions so stick around
for that